étape par étape une petite blague à
voici un album ma fille molly part
directe s'est redressée
e tiens c'est eric zemmour
[Rires]
eric zemmour y rôde dans un musée hélas
le directeur du musée vient vous le voir
il reconnaît des bouchons et zemmour
j'espère vous êtes un con rappelle
comment le mec du musée parce que je
sais pas combien ça marche en france six
mois - francis me dit bonjour monsieur
zemmour je vais vous aider à faire cette
visite dans le musée donc monsieur
zemmour iran qui s'arrêtent devant un
qu'est-ce qui a trop
promis quoi ça tape t'inquiète ça tape
ça nous inquiète abbas a pas changé ici
la technique
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
la loi du début c'est eric zemmour qui
rentrent dans un musée et là il ya le
directeur du musée qui vient le voir et
dit bonjour monsieur zemmour tient le
reconnaît lui d'écouter je vais vous
aider à faire cette visite alors il
marche avec zemmour est un moment donné
peut s'user moore il s'arrête devant
devant un tableau il dit alors qu'est ce
que c'est dégueulasse et le prie
monsieur dit miser l'utilité monsieur
zemmour c'est dégueulasse mais c'est un
picasso il marche il s'arrête devant un
autre tabloïd genre ça c'est répugnant
du coup monsieur zemmour c'est répugnant
mais c'est un picasso et les cinq îles
troisième fois il dit alors ça c'est
dégueulasse et lespignan si jamais vu un
truc aussi dégueulasse de ma vie l'autre
je dis ça monsieur sammy roi
je peux rester huit heures
pour les uniques sont comme ça on dit
pas on est pour un parti c'est un autre
quartier mais qu'il arrive dans un
village ancien
des problèmes avec la première c'est que
tu attaques un autre candidat n'a alors
pas notre candidat c'est un candidat il
arrive dans un village dit voilà je me
présente aux élections qui sait qu'elles
sont
quelles sont les revendications et
j'écoutais neurones à deux sans vie de
deux revendications
les villageois disons-le à deux
revendications la première revendication
on n'a pas de médecin dans le village et
tu quand on sort je n'ai pas de médecin
prend son téléphone
a été comme un fouet alors oui c'est pas
normal je veux deux médecins pour la
région sinon ça va partir en cacahuète
et raccroche et dit c'est quoi la
deuxième revendication
bah y'a pas de raison ici protéger
bayard
radio
c'est que evian fait que des blagues il
s'est éteint j'adorais moi j'adorais
bouder tu veux je te disais il ya est
aussi bien on fait que des blagues la
même blague racontée par quelqu'un des
bouddhas c'est passible de prison et
c'était dur est ce que quelqu'un a une
blague à nous raconter là on voit la
différence même équipe au québec vous
les aigles à capuche est ce que tu as
déjà vu une tomate chanter non match et
j'avais une carotte râpée
[Rires]
raconte des blagues l'impression qu'elle
donne des infos
c'est ça